معجب من الحزن عامه منصات اليوم والاخبار
عنوانها خساره عملاق المسرح اللبناني
روميو لحود اللي من الوقت اعلان وفاته وما
زال اسمه ترند على المنصات روميو لحود
مؤلف وملحن ومخرج ومصمم استعراضات قدم على
مدار عشرات او على مدار عشرات السنوات
الكثير من الاعمال والالحان المجاهدين
احنا وصلنا او خلينا قبل
فقره عرض اهم اعماله خلينا نتكلم عنه
الراحل ونحن مشاهدينا همم وصلنا الاختام
محمد حلقاتنا اليوم لكن في تفاعلكم حبينا
انه نقدم لفه صغيره اللي روح الفنان
الكبير رومي وهذا هو المقطع اللي كنت بقول
لكم عنه اخترنا له مجموعه من اعماله تكريم
الى اللقاء
قالولي العيد بعيوني
وحداري بعيني
دلوني
غمضت عيوني تشروف العيد لا شفت العيد ولا
درب بعين وابعت من الليل من يومها
بتشرق شمس العيد
[موسيقى]
يوم بيدك بكره بعيد
ساعدوني احلى عوايد عودوا
وانزاح عنك
الزمن بيعوده
[موسيقى]
يا حبيبي يا حبيبي حبيبي
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
يوم الفرح